I can't get a television series even
though I have eight Emmy nominations and
two wins and nobody will let me do a
special at this time even though I hold
the Guinness Book of World Records for
the most televised standard specials of
any comedian male a female living or
dead Kathy Griffin ready for her
comeback after thinking as she lost
almost everything in the wake of the
Trump photo scandal
what was the back-up plan the back-up
plan was kind of what it always is I was
still writing I was taking meetings at
my house and even that was a learning
process like I learned that I would meet
with networks and they would send a
female development person and I would do
a pitch because one thing I wanted to do
was like a docu-series like I was
reading about this and nobody would pick
it up people in the room would say yes
then it goes the check writers and they
say no yeah I think it's important that
women understand only men can decide
what goes on the air now did you think
about independently doing a documentary
or docu-series like just filming just
you have the footage I did I did and I
have quite a bit of footage so but it's
not easy to watch because some of it was
very in the moment and nobody was
interested nobody not one person but I
still felt like the docu-series could
have been good I just loved that Leah
Remini show and so I thought oh she's
figured out a way to take a serious
topic and make it accessible for
everybody so look if that happens in the
future anything can happen but I'm just
so glad to be able to at least stand on
stage and the one benefit of me not
working for a network studio is I mean
when you say unbridled she's not holding
back I mean I did a show in Vancouver
three nights ago I went three and a half
hours incredible I just want to warn
people warn your your viewers either
bring your colostomy bag or plan to take
many peaks and by the way speaking of P
tick tock until that tape the comedian
will take the stage in the US for the
first time since her scandal this month
and she's got a clear message it's just
so important to me that younger comics
younger LGBT folks younger people of
color younger Hispanic folks can look at
this old bird and go all right she's
still standing and that's what's really
important to me
[Music]